LOUIS GRAY: Welcome back to
Google Developers Live at I/O.
I'm Louis Gray.
I'm joined here with John Hanke
from the Niantic Project.
Welcome, John.
JOHN HANKE: Thank you.
LOUIS GRAY: Now the
Niantic Project
actually is really cool.
I think you guys have a couple
of games that are out.
You've got "Project Ingress,"
and you have "Field Trip,"
which isn't so much a game.
But both of them are really tied
to discovering the world
around you.
So I want a couple questions
to start us off.
First of all, what is
the Niantic Project?
It is part of Google, right?
JOHN HANKE: Well, we try
to keep it a little bit
mysterious.
But yes, it is part of Google.
We're kind of like a little
startup in Google.
And I guess the goal of the
Niantic Group is to explore
these kinds of applications in
mobile that use location and
explore this area of ubiquitous
computing, things
that are telling you about the
world around you, helping you
explore, but without necessarily
using an app in a
conventional sense.
LOUIS GRAY: You have a
history of working
with startups, anyway.
You came from Keyhole with the
Google acquisition of Keyhole
and really became the backbone
of Google Earth and a lot of
the other work that
we've done.
It really seems you have
a passion for maps.
Help us understand how both of
those projects, Ingress and
Field Trip put together, are
helping Google's location
information get better or
helping users know more about
their world.
JOHN HANKE: Yeah.
I love maps, obviously.
I came in in 2004 with Keyhole
and was the Product Lead for
that part of Google for
about seven years.
During that time, I used to
daydream about other things
that we could do with
the mapping
data and the resources.
And one of those things
was a game.
And as smartphones started to
proliferate, I felt like the
time was right to tap into all
of the mapping data that we
have and to create an awesome
game for mobile that would
encourage people to really get
out and explore their world.
And that's really the spirit
behind both "Ingress" and
"Field Trip."
LOUIS GRAY: So let's talk a
little bit about Ingress.
What is the deal, anyway?
For those who haven't played
it, how do you describe it?
And what's the difference
between the Resistance and the
Enlightened, for those
who don't know?
JOHN HANKE: The story behind
Ingress is, it's a science
fiction themed story that really
puts a layer of reality
onto the world around you.
So there's a mysterious energy
that's been tapped into in a
lab in Geneva, Switzerland.
And through the story of
Ingress, you begin to learn a
little bit more about
that energy.
It's called exotic matter
in our world.
And as it turns out, it's
all around the globe.
And it's concentrated in these
places called portals, which
often are pieces of public
art or museums
or historical sites.
And you use the Ingress
application on your Android
phone to discover those places
in the real world and then to
tap into them.
And you can mine virtual
objects.
You can interact with them and
you can try to take control of
those locations for one
of two fractions--
LOUIS GRAY: One of
the two teams.
JOHN HANKE: --the Enlightened
and the Resistance.
LOUIS GRAY: And so as a player,
you pick a team, and
you go find these portals.
And you have to blow them up and
use up your XM energy and
all of that.
Now poor me, I find myself often
trying to take my Level
3 or Level 4 skills.
I just can't blow up
a Level 8 portal.
When you look at Ingress, is
there room for the novice
player who's just starting it
now or wants to get into it?
Or have all the places basically
been locked down by
the hardcore players?
JOHN HANKE: Yeah.
There's definitely room.
One of the things that we didn't
expect with Ingress was
how much teamwork and
collaboration
would end up emerging.
But we found that people really
love getting together
and playing in groups
and having meetups.
We're having one here in San
Francisco this week.
But we have them all
around the country,
all around the world.
So it's a great way for a new
player to kind of get into the
game would be to meet up with
other Ingress players.
And some of the more senior
players really love taking a
newbie under their wing and
showing them the ropes and
also helping them level up in
the game and become powerful
enough to start affecting
the real global battle.
LOUIS GRAY: And you have
something special going on
here at Google I/O.
Is that right?
JOHN HANKE: Yeah.
There's kind of a game
within a game.
So we're doing two things.
We're doing Operation Fan-Out,
which all I/O attendees are
able to take part in that.
And if you level up during I/O,
you get a really cool
Ingress t-shirt.
If you show up as a Level 8
already, we have a special
Level 8 t-shirt for you.
And we have another thing
that's open to non-I/O
attendees as well.
It's called Operation
Bowstring.
And that's being played out
across San Francisco.
And it culminates in an event
on Thursday night at Cupid
Span, which is down in the
Embarcadero, with a meetup
over at the Alchemist
bar later.
LOUIS GRAY: "Ingress" right
now is Android-only.
"Field Trip" is available for
both Android and iOS.
How do you see that the users
of the different operating
systems use the apps
differently?
JOHN HANKE: Yeah.
I guess if you were to look at
Field Trip, it's available for
iOS and for Android.
It's rolling out globally
today, actually.
Initially, it was a US-only
launch and in the UK.
There are subtle differences.
We've noticed that Android
users tend to
spike on the weekends.
And they're out using and so
maybe exploring more than
their iOS counterparts.
I don't know if that means that
Android users are more
into exploration
than iOS users.
But yeah, there are
small differences.
LOUIS GRAY: Should we expect
to see even more products
coming out of Niantic Project?
JOHN HANKE: Well,
you never know.
We are looking at a range
of technologies
in this mobile space.
We're very interested in
wearable computing and what
you can do with it.
But the things that we're
putting all of our energies
behind right now are "Ingress"
and "Field Trip."
LOUIS GRAY: So I should expect
to have "Ingress" on my Glass
any day now is what
I'm hearing.
JOHN HANKE: Well, I think Glass
would make an excellent
platform for some
awesome games.
So we'll see about that.
LOUIS GRAY: Yeah.
Absolutely.
Now one last question
before we wrap.
Niantic Project, as a startup
at Google, do you have more
freedom to do more things?
What does that mean to be within
Google but also be
within this tiny
little enclave?
JOHN HANKE: It was a
great opportunity.
It was set up with Larry's
support so that we could
pursue this area across ideas
and concepts, from mobile to
social to geo, and try to weave
those things together in
new ways to explore what could
be done to create apps that
were really native to the new
wave of devices that will be
coming, wearables.
LOUIS GRAY: Excellent.
Well, I appreciate you taking
the time, John.
I know we've been real quick
jumping into "Ingress" and
"Field Trip." For those of you
who haven't download those
apps already, definitely
check them out.
We have more exclusive GDL
at I/O content coming.
And we'll be talking about
Google Now with
Baris Gultekin at 3:25.
So please stay on the stream
and enjoy your sessions.
We'll be right back.